a resilient person is capable of
standing up to things in the face of
fear and moving forward voluntarily
difficulties are coming for you that's
part of being a human but not enough
people are willing to build that mental
emotional toughness rise and shine it's
an espresso time what's up belief nation
it's Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message
develop resilience over to you Jordan
beep Peterson also if you want to know
what Jordan Peterson and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is in the description below
if you're gonna speak effectively you
have to know way more than you're
talking about
[Music]
life is difficult and you cannot protect
your children what you can do is prepare
them and you can prepare them to be
strong and courageous and truthful and
resilient and reciprocal in their
interactions with other people and that
means you equip them for what life will
be which is a at minimum a series of
difficult challenges and and often more
than that because of course people go
through very difficult times in their
lives and a resilient person is capable
of standing up to things in the face of
fear and moving forward voluntarily
convinced of their own competence and
ability to prevail and so the primary
your primary goal as a parent apart from
facilitating your child's social
desirability which is a major obligation
on your part is to encourage your
children and to and I mean that
literally to instill in them a sense of
courage in the face of the difficulties
of life and not to protect them from
that we don't even want to be protected
from those difficulties because a major
part of life and its meaning is the the
challenge that comes with confronting
difficulties difficulties are coming for
you that's part of being a human there
isn't a life without any adversity or
any any difficulties they're coming for
you now how do you respond do you want
to be the victim or the victor do you
want to succumb to it or do you want to
grow through it it's one of the most
important decisions that you ever have
to make as a human when you get faced
with challenges what is your identity
what do you believe in are you the kind
of person who all backed down from a
challenge who any time they're hit with
adversity you you go inside you cry you
complain you get upset you blame other
people or you say I'm stronger than this
I'm gonna grow from this I'm gonna be
better because of this ultimately I
believe that your purpose comes from
your pain and that the more pain that
you've been through and you've come
through the other side it actually
allows you to help more people the
people who've gone on and done the best
things for the planet
the people who had the biggest missions
have had the biggest impact often had
the biggest pain they suffered the most
through some adversity and they got
through it and instead of succumbing to
it instead of being the victim they
became the Victoire and they use their
desire to
serve and help others to go off and
create something amazing for humanity
that could be you when you're faced with
this adversity that's in front of you
that could be you what are you gonna do
with it
are you gonna complain or are you gonna
change the world I like to see myself
and other entrepreneurs as a tree I have
this analogy be a tree what does a tree
do a tree breathes in poison carbon
dioxide it's poison for you for humans
is poison
breeze in poison eats it grows from it
and then spits out oxygen positivity
that's what I see is our roles whatever
hate is out there whatever negativity is
out there whatever problems whatever
difficulties whatever adversities are
out there your job is to eat them digest
grow from them and then spit out
positivity make the world a better place
right I think deep down that's what we
all want to do we want to make the world
a better place than how we found it and
that's how you do it that this adversity
that you're going through right now
actually is the greatest thing of all
time but the pain and suffering that
you're going through right now actually
is amazing because that's going to be
your purpose because you're gonna make
sure that nobody else ever has to suffer
from this thing that you're going
through right now ever again because
you're gonna save tens hundreds
thousands millions of people from having
to suffer the same feat that you did
because it's gonna be your purpose now
you're gonna serve you're gonna give
back you can make something amazing out
of it you're gonna be the tree and so
take down that mindset that whatever's
in front of you right now whatever pain
difficulty challenge judgment that
you're facing right now is the best is
your opportunity not just to show people
and show yourself what you're made of
but ultimately to be able to serve
others in an amazing way because now
you've just found your purpose and
you're gonna make sure that nobody else
in the world ever has to suffer the same
fate that you suffered your purpose
comes from your pain go be a tree now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that I want to know what is the
equivalent for you of being a tree what
are you eating right now what are you
eating that doesn't taste good what are
you eating what are you breathing in but
you're gonna eat it digest it build it
grow from it and then spit up positivity
what is that thing what's the poison
right now in your
I love to hear from you put in the
comments below
ten you know I kind of called myself I'm
a meathead I just lift weights and put
him down right I had kind of painted
myself into that corner why not go run a
marathon so I trained for six weeks and
went and ran a marathon it was the most
painful thing I ever did but I realized
that was more the suffering and the pain
and the more pain I had the more put me
into the zone of wanting to dominate so
it is a superpower so I must now go back
and put myself into these challenges Rob
claiming I was afraid of heights took on
a six-week challenge started climbing
Rob's wanted to fight a professional MMA
fighter so I hired him trained for six
weeks one of the Ring and got my ass
kicked and choked out but each time I
did that it gave me the sense of I can
get over any obstacle and if I can get
over getting choked out and punched and
the pain of 26.2 miles is a marathon or
overcoming my fear of heights surely I
can build a business surely I can take
some criticism online right but not
enough people are willing to build that
mental emotional toughness and the
moment they do though persevere if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon if
you want more Jordan Peterson check out
his 12 rules for life video that we made
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there Junction
is like take a look at the people that
are around you and if they're not on the
side of what's good for you
then walk away